the Academy Awards the biggest night in
Hollywood since last night he's an
Academy award-winning actor and she is
the most beautiful brilliant and
talented woman in all of show business
and I'm not just saying that because she
revived my career here a Robert Downey
jr. and Tina Fey
great movies begin with great writing
what does an actor look for in a script
specificity emotional honesty catharsis
and what does a writer look for in an
actor memorizing not paraphrasing fear
of ad-libbing actors once scripts with
social relevance warm-weather locations
phone call scenes that can be shot
separately from that insane actress that
I hate and long dense columns of
uninterrupted monologue turning the page
and for instance seeing the phrase Tony
Stark continued and we writers dream of
a future where actors are mostly
computer-generated and their
performances can be adjusted by us on a
laptop alone it's a collaboration a
collaboration between handsome gifted
people and sickly little mole people
it's really not you should just say
whatever we doing one I should just say
that uh here are the nominees for Best
Original Screenplay The Hurt Locker by
Mark Boal inglorious basterds by Quentin
Tarantino the messenger by Alessandro
kamon and Oren Moe vermin a serious man
by Joel Coen and Ethan Coen up
screenplay by Bob Peterson and Pete
docter story by Pete docter Bob Peterson
and Tom McCarthy and
the winner is and the winner is Mark
Boal for The Hurt Locker
this is the first Academy Award for Mark
Boal he has two nominations tonight for
The Hurt Locker
oh my god Wow Thank You Academy you
honor me and humble me with this more
than more than you know I was a reporter
back from Iraq with the idea for a story
about these men on the front lines of an
unpopular war I thought it might make a
movie the result wildly exceeded my
expectations and that is thanks to so
many people to summon entertainment to
our amazing cast and crew and most of
all to one extraordinary individual and
visionary filmmaker Kathryn Bigelow this
belongs to you I would also like to
thank and dedicate this to the troops
the hundred fifteen thousand who are
still in Iraq that 120 thousand
Afghanistan and the more than 30,000
wounded and 4,000 who have not made it
home and to my father who didn't live to
see this but inspired me and got me up
here and he passed away a month ago he
would have really liked this a lot
thanks to thank
you